Elon Musk announced his plan to remove
the block feature on X in violation of
Apple and Google Play Store guidelines I
genuinely do not understand why Elon
Musk would want to remove the block
feature he says block is going to be
deleted as a feature except for DMs he
says it makes no sense
I don't know it makes a lot of sense
what do you guys what do you like why
not just mute no because block stops
someone from basically stalking you but
then they just make a fake account and
stock you man I'll block that one too
but then they just make another one and
I'll block that one they make 50 more
man you're busy but then it makes so
much time and I'll block them every
single time I think it's better to mute
someone and they don't know they're
muted so they can scream but see they're
a prominent high profile people with
millions of followers who don't make
fake accounts and their job exists to
stalk your Twitter take you your tweets
out of context and insult you and smear
and make money off it I'm gonna make it
harder for them by blocking them so now
they'll have to make a fake account but
many of them do not do it someone
suggested if the mute button also made
it so they can't post or reply to any of
your stuff that's a block no it's just a
lot yeah but they could still view your
stuff right I can I can open anyone's
Twitter page in a private Tab and see
their profile if they've blocked me
right but you have to seek it out
blocking someone makes it so that they
you don't appear in their feet anymore
and out of sight out of mind it helps
tremendously there's another thing you
can do it's a force to unfollow follow
where you go to the person who's
annoying and you block and unblock right
away what this does is if these people
are stalking in her and like just being
annoying or like I I try to use this
word lightly harassing harassing to
varying degrees it's hard to on the
internet but there's a point where you
can get to it if they're posting your
address and I've had people post photos
of my house and address and things like
that if I block them they'll go nuts
they'll make a fake account and then
they'll start using that account to
bother me again so one thing you can do
is block and unblock really quick
they're no longer following you and now
your posts won't appear in their feed
and they might slowly forget about you
there's a couple ways you can do it but
more importantly let's just put it this
way there are prominent high profile
non-profit organizations who have staff
who don't run sock puppet accounts and
if you block them they stop talking
about you
that's why blocking works there's other
things too I mean some people do not if
if you're telling me
they might make a fake profile and stalk
me and harass me anyway okay well I'll
make it harder for him at least give me
some options it's like don't say Well
they're gonna come they're gonna break
in your house anyways just open your
windows it's like no I'll lock my
windows sure they can smash the window
and climb in but always make it harder
for them but it's kind of like blocking
someone's like making them wear a
blindfold so they can't see you like
it's like yeah but it's not real it
doesn't because well bro if your goal is
to make it so someone can't see your
social media you can't do it they can
always make a new account and it works
the guys who work at Media Matters you
don't make fake accounts that's it how
do you there's no way to know that there
okay bro yes there is and I don't want
to start talking about private security
stuff Beyond this but you are completely
wrong blocking matters it is one of the
first things we do in a security
assessment when you're dealing with
people swatting and doxing and sending
bomb threats the first thing you do is
you make it harder for them to interact
with you and your content and mute does
not do that every time they try and call
your number to doctor to call a bomb for
or whatever it just goes into the void
it never never picks up the point is you
want them you want to be harder for them
to see you
that's it you want to reduce visibility
it is not perfect but it is the first
action you take when dealing with
stalking and harassing it also it it
prevents them from like interacting with
your tweets and your followers and your
followers posting porn and other that
kind of stuff matters about like how
they can interact with your account is
different when it's a block versus uh
and some of these accounts have 50 000
followers and they don't run sock
puppets their goal is with their account
to harass you to gain followers if they
can no longer do that they'll Target
someone else that's why adding to the
mute function that they can't post on
your stuff
that's a block it's just a no but they
can still see your stuff and they still
can right now I personally think that if
they're thinking of like actually
removing the block feature then they
should make it a policy that you're not
allowed to have an anonymous account
because I'm in favor of keeping the
block I agree with you as somebody who
has been harassed online and has had
stalkers and you know people be really
you know weird online uh you sometimes
have to block them right because people
get obsessive like P there are stalkers
that you know latch on to you and
sometimes for your own safety as Tim
said you have to block them because it
becomes overbearing they start because
they reply to your posts yeah with
pictures of your house it's also a way
like they can't they can't say oh
bullying is against our terms of service
you can't have people saying that
bullying is not acceptable online but
then also say okay you're not allowed to
block somebody you have a right to
decide what you don't want to see I
don't personally think that people
should be de-platformed I don't think
that we should be banning people but
every single person person should have
the right to filter what they see and if
they want to block somebody just like
you can block someone on your phone you
should be able to block them you have
the right to limit at who has access to
you yeah you're not silent you have the
right to say you don't have I don't want
you interacting with me or anything that
I am doing you have that right in
reality like in in the physical world
you can leave someone's presence and
then you just don't go where they are
and if they show up you leave or you
might have to call the cops or whatever
um but you have the right to say that
there's one thing I just saw Linda Arena
just uh tweeted a few minutes ago our
user safety on X is our number one
priority and we're building something
better than the current state of block
and mute please keep the feedback coming
this was in real in response yeah just
like just like just like just like
Twitter now has uh content creators
right all right well we should send
Linda this clip so she can listen to us
because these are good things um yeah I
think something could be better than
blocking me I've always found block to
be kind of ridiculous because people can
just make fake accounts anyway you can't
it's like I can't make you shut your
eyes when you're looking at me that's up
to you so I can ask you to leave I can
close my ears off but I can't shut your
mouth Phil like I can't do the fly guys
there are people on Twitter who are
reply guys they have uh there's one guy
with a hundred and twenty thousand
followers only because he he refreshes
your page waits for a new tweet and then
immediately posts something gross or
offensive or insulting
if you block them they can't do that
anymore they won't make a new account
because they're trying to build
followers on their current account so
blocking Works more importantly there
are people who do this and they will
also post threats photos of family
members private information you block
them they can't do it anymore
there's a bunch of reasons why blocking
is important yeah we need an
amalgamation of the of the of the
abilities because I don't when I block
someone I can still see them I don't
want to see those people I want to mute
them I never want to think about that
when you block someone Twitter stops
showing you everything from not always
that's the fact it'll say this user has
been muted or blocked I'm like I don't I
know that's so don't show me that crap I
don't want to know that they're posted
so if you erase them from my field of
view if you block someone and then
someone else quote tweets them and says
something it'll say this tweet is
unavailable and then you can choose to
go to the person's profile and view the
Tweet by clicking view tweet but they
limit what you see giving you the option
I also have a policy of anyone who
blocks me that I see I block back
because then they're going to play that
game where they don't want you to be
able to read what they're saying about
you but they're going to go to your
tweets and start doing the same like
doing the inverse I personally love mute
um something at mines we didn't have a
mute function in the beginning I don't
know if it has a mute function right now
it's got a block function but block is
like it's not that I don't want you to
know what I'm up to I just don't want to
listen to you
are you guys uh familiar you're familiar
with steam I know Tim Andy and are you
guys familiar with steam yep so it's
just a yeah it's like a video game
software on your computer if you're
caught cheating it'll ban your computer
so it doesn't matter if you make a new
account it knows you're logging in from
the same piece of hardware and you will
never be able to log into that Hardware
bin and play yeah that's my question for
you guys would you guys be in favor of
like a hardware Ban for like so you'd be
able to block in if he's being gross
nope on a hardware band because uh it
can you can easily capture the wrong
person with a hardware band oh yeah yeah
I don't like someone like imagine
someone going on a library computer so
this actually happened with a lot of uh
a lot of vpns and stuff the whole
network gets banned because one person
uses a certain you know router or
whatever and then that IP is banned
instantly it's a lot of these networks
Auto ban VPN IPS anyway I think Banning
people is a failure of a concept you
should be banning accounts if the
account violates terms and then if they
make a new account it's fair game if you
want to put in your terms that if
someone it's been banned can't make a
new account I think that's dirty because
people change and become better people
and that's the idea is we want to make
each other we should be banned for
anything unless you're inciting violence
you know I just think that the terms of
service need to be identical to the
United States Constitution
look like you have Linda yaccarino that
just came out and basically said as a
way to to kind of soften the blow the
reality check that hey guys just kidding
you know they all lied to you and they
said that the new ownership of uh
Twitter or X as they want to call it is
now pro-free speech it's not okay
because they're creating these
Advertiser block lists but instead of
actually saying hey we're going to ban
people that we don't like they're gonna
say hey if you're a content creator you
can you know buy Twitter blue and then
you can be a content creator and you're
going to get paid except if you're
lawful or awful we're going to put you
on a blacklist and that's what they just
said that they're gonna do at Twitter so
it's basically the same censorship
regime that we saw at Twitter 1.0 but
they're trying to play good cap good cop
bad cop by putting the blame on the
advertise so instead of it being oh Elon
Musk or Linda yac Arena or censoring me
it's now oh well sorry you're on our
Advertiser block list you have to take
it up with the advertisers I kind of
take it but ultimately they're the ones
that well they did that advertisement
block list let's talk about this um I
did I did just get paid uh on Twitter I
got paid uh 4 377 dollars
I had a total in the past 28 days of 241
million impressions and the reason I
disclose all of this to you is because
there are a lot of people with
substantially less Impressions who got
paid more and people with more
Impressions who got paid substantially
less have you disclosed how much you got
you did you tweeted it right yeah so I
need to check and see
um because I don't think you can check
your impressions on your phone you have
to be on your computer to check it I
think so I need to see what the
Impressions were but I know they're
going to be over 100 million but I have
at least over 150 million impressions
every single month and I just got paid
today and I only got paid 190 dollars
and 22 cents so if you go if you open a
browser and login and go to
analytics.twitter.com it'll show you
right here what your impressions are but
you got to log in on the browser and do
desktop site or whatever thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time